so a question that I get asked all the
time is to briefly summarize what my PhD
is all about and obviously that's kind
of a difficult thing to do because in
order to even start the PhD I had to do
a four-year physics course and the PhD
itself is a project that takes between
three and four years so condensing that
information down to somebody who's from
outside of the field
is a little bit difficult to say the
least but I'm going to try and do that
in this video and to make it more
interesting I'm going to try and do that
in under 60 seconds that way I can never
do that here we go three two one go
right so my PhD is in the field of
climate physics and more specifically
than that it's in stratosphere
troposphere coupling and what the PhD is
basically about is trying to answer the
question of how weather at fifteen
kilometers and above above the surface
affects the weather at the surface now
the way in which we try and do that is
by looking events called sudden
stratospheric warming and these are
really really violent events in the
Earth's atmosphere and they occur where
the polar vortex which is this big
doughnut shaped a lot lump of air over
the North Pole slows down and
accompanied by that slowing is a huge
very very quick warming of the
atmosphere over the North Pole and that
goes from the level of the vortex right
the way down to the surface and what
that does is it effects storm tracks and
it affects the pressure pattern at the
surface and so it changes the weather so
what I do in my PhD is construct
different physical models of increasing
complexity that look at that situation
ask the question given us particular
bandwidth vortex what happens at the
surface boom 60 seconds now that's only
like a really brief introduction to the
field if this sounds interesting to you
then in two weeks time starting in two
weeks I'm going to be doing a series on
my channel of three crash course style
videos so like 10 minutes long serving
as an introduction to atmospheric
physics to the stratosphere and to
sudden stratospheric warming
respectively over three episodes so if
you like the sound of that then make
sure you stick around and if you haven't
already you know subscribe to the
channel why don't you teams have two
keeps and I hope this kind of cleared
things up a little bit it probably made
things more complicated but if you want
to make those things clearer then you
know come back in two weeks time next
week there's going to be a video
on our client works on Cambridge and
basically trying to answer every
question you could possibly have about
the application procedure and in the
video and also directing you to other
resources so that's going to next week
stratosphere stuff starting in two weeks
thanks for watching and if you haven't
already then you can follow me on I
should probably point to stuff on the
screen shouldn't I follow me on Twitter
and you can also like me on Facebook and
that's it oh you know you can subscribe
to the channel and like the video again
pushing myself is like I'm a product and
if you're a PhD student by chance
watching this video then please put down
in the comments
a brief version of what your thesis is
going to be about and what your project
is because if you're really interesting
to see if there are actually any of you
out there and what you guys are up to
you know we're not alone solidarity